- Last time you were here though,
you said your childhood dream was to sing,
and you recently were
on The Masked Singer.
- Yeah, I was.
I did pretty well.
(audience clapping)
- You made that happen. Check.
- Check, right?
- Yeah, check that box.
- It was nice.
And it's nice to be in a
mask because, you, all the,
you know, preconceived
notions about yourself of like
"I'm a comedian, what am I doing singing?"
- Yeah.
- I could just disappear in it. And even-
- It's kind of brilliant.
- It's so good.
- Yeah.
- It makes you feel like
free and I actually sang
Since U Been Gone.
- I know.
- In like the, the Battle.
And I won against The Avocado.
I think it was Adam Carolla.
(audience clapping)
Thank you.
I sang better than Adam Carolla.
- I kicked that avocado's behind.
That's amazing.
- But it is, I mean-
- That's a big song.
- It is a big song, but it's the song.
And it was, it won that
I had a lot of practice
singing in showers and cars, and like,
it just, I felt like
really prepared for it.
I mean, you're such an inspiration in, in
in a way that is like too lofty.
I'm, I'm taking voice lessons right now
and I just got a new teacher.
- I love that.
- And I, he asked me to bring
in some music to be like,
cause he's very like, "we can do anything.
You can be anything you want."
And he's like, "who do
you wanna sound like?"
I'm like, "Kelly Clarkson."
He's like, "except that."
He was like "what?"
He goes "what? I didn't
actually mean that."
- Aim for a talented vocalist, ma'am.
- No. He was like, "maybe Tom Waits."
I'm like, "wait, wait a second."
One of the housewives.
Maybe, Countess Luann?"
But yeah, that was a humbling moment.
But I was just like, "no,
I'd like to sound like
Kelly Clarkson." My goal
is to sound like you
if you like got walking
pneumonia or something.
Like that's, if you got like
kicked in the throat by-
- I've actually been on
tour with walking pneumonia.
- I bet you sounded amazing still.
- Did not.
But you are seriously pursuing.
- I am.
- I love this.
- It just feels so much,
I love doing comedy,
I'm on tour right now.
Nothing feels more vulnerable,
and like makes me feel
alive as doing comedy.
You just, but there's
something just so emotive
and sincere about singing and I just...
- Yeah.
- I just felt that on the Masked Singer.
I was like, "I gotta chase this."
So, I don't know.
I'm 38 pursuing a new career.
- Who cares?
- You get one life, dude.
Do what you want.
(audience clapping)
- I mean, you started doing this.
Who knew that you were gonna
be an amazing talk show host?
- Not me.
- But here you are.
- But it's such a natural thing for you.
- I think if you enjoy something-
- Yeah.
- Just go for it.
And we're all singers here.
- You're a singer too.
- Yes.
- Oh hell to the no.
- Yes, you are.
- I'm not a singer.
- I've seen Coco.
- Listen, quickly, my son and daughter
let me know every day that dad,
"you're a terrible singer."
But I always counter, "yeah.
But I'm a professional singer,
cause I got paid for Coco."
- Yes, yes.
- Don't come at me.